before we say goodbye we'd like to play
a quick round up truth or dare
we do anything we say anything and we
have sherilyn stratton here
uh sherilyn hi hi
did i say your name correctly yes you
did oh thank god thank god and thank god
you wore that pink look how great that
is
fuchsia fuchsia
[Laughter]
i love that fuchsia dress thank you
you're welcome all right what's it gonna
be is it gonna be a truth or a dare i
have a truth okay
so drew have you ever
gone skipping skinny dipping and if so
what's your story
i mean which time
uh a hotel pool
at the chateau marmont in los angeles
for i don't know about 15 years
um
and uh a great like midnight jump in the
lake of winnipesaukee in new hampshire
my favorite lake in the world i think
um
and um i will say
uh birthday suit or bathing suit if you
see a body of water or rain coming down
from the sky just get in it
you'll never regret it you will always
dry off pretty quickly
and you will be immediately
transformed in a nature baptism and i
just can't recommend it enough uh
recently my girls and i actually got to
go somewhere which was such a blessing
and it started pouring rain and we were
at a beach and we ran outside
and we took a rain shower
and an ocean bath and we even brought
out some shampoo
and conditioner and and really did and
we like bathed in the ocean and then yes
rain shower ocean bath and it's one of
my favorite moments in the film strip of
my life it made
it was the greatest moment ever
i did have clothes on however okay good
good have you ever skinny dipped ross
thanks so much for watching everybody
um uh
yeah
where when my house my house my house
never in public oh god no never dear god
no but yeah you know my pool my house
gates locked
[Music]